voilà donc pour les éléments nouveaux
première réaction celle de Jean Cannes
le président du Conseil représentatif
des institutions juives de France le
Christ écoutez ce qu'il a dit à
Strasbourg à Stéphane Ely sur ses
nouveaux éléments
prononcer sur le fait de savoir si le
corps monte a été empalé ou non il est
suffisamment odieux de constater que le
cadavre de ce pauvre homme était exhumé
et que l'on est estimé de voir recouvrir
son corps d'une étoile de David qui a
été prélevée sur le monument funéraire
de ce cimetière je crois que ce qui
compte c'est que ceci a eu lieu et que
sont les deux caractères racistes de
l'acte a été établi par conséquent tout
le reste sera une question de recherche
de la vérité dont je répète je fais
confiance aux autorités de notre pays
quoi qu'il en soit ces éléments nouveaux
bien sûr ne change en rien la gravité de
ce crime seulement cela amène tout de
même à se poser quelques questions
Marcel triang
un Walker collectif provoqué par des
faits spectaculaires 34 tombe Israélites
profanées un cadavre exhumé et ce mot
terrible empalé un mot chargé d'angoisse
qui ramène à la surface les horreurs des
supplices du Moyen-Âge l'enquête que
nous avons menée à Carpentras et que
confirme les propos du procureur général
de Nîmes nous permet donc aujourd'hui
d'affirmer que le mot empaler ne
correspondait pas tout à fait à la
réalité des faits l'horreur est la même
le geste innommable mais il s'agirait
plus exactement d'une mise en scène
macabre d'un acte d'ingures comme il y a
des mots d'injures le piqué n'était pas
enfoncé dans le corps mais avait été
placé dans la position de l'empalement
comme pour insulter la mémoire de
Monsieur germon et par personne
interposée toute la communauté juive
nous sommes les premiers à déplorer
d'avoir à étaler ainsi des détails aussi
morbides mais nous nous devons ce soir
de poser solennellement plusieurs
questions aux fonctionnaires de la
police judiciaire au magistrat en charge
de l'enquête et au ministre de
l'Intérieur
le mot empalement ayant été employés à
tort dans l'émotion des premiers moments
pourquoi les enquêteurs n'ont-ils pas
rectifié leur premier communiqué
lorsqu'ils ont eu connaissance des faits
exacts pourquoi quelques heures à peine
après la découverte de la profanation le
ministre de l'Intérieur a-t-il ordonné
le blackout total non seulement sur
l'enquête ce qui légitime mais aussi sur
la description véridique des faits
constatés par les policiers les
magistrats et le médecin légiste dans le
même temps où les autorités incité à
juste titre les Français à se mobiliser
elle ne les jugaient pas de digne d'être
informé précisément et complètement sur
la réalité de l'événement à la lumière
des dernières révélations la révolte
collective provoquée par la profanation
de Carpentras demeure parfaitement
justifiée mais on ne peut à la fois
faire appel à la responsabilité des
citoyens et refuser de les traiter comme
des adultes
ce soir